hey i'm christian i'm an outdoor
adventure photographer and
i've been living on the road for two
plus years okay
so i know i mentioned in my last video
that
this video would be about how i make
money and earn
a remote income while living on the road
but
for the past month i've mostly just been
in the mountains doing what i love
most i've been hiking camping and taking
photos
it's so beautiful this time of year so i
figured i'd share what i've been up to
and some behind the scenes of a few
recent photography trips in the
washington back country
in this episode i'll give you a glimpse
into what i pack for these overnights
and
what kind of camera gear i take into the
mountains just so you have an idea of
what i actually
do as an adventure photographer before i
dive into
how i've turned it into a career thanks
for sticking around
excited to show you guys a little bit of
my current backyard
we are hiking in the mount baker
wilderness
passing a lot of people on the trail got
my face mask and that's nathaniel
hello
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
i feel like we've crossed into narnia
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here is the mosquito refuge
while sleeping in the backcountry really
nice view
and up here is home for the night
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so i was originally going to go over
what i pack
um in the van but kind of ran out of
time so i'm just going to unpack my bag
here at camp and show you guys what i
typically take
out into the back country all right so
here it is fully packed it's the osprey
65
10 liter and i'm gonna unpack it for you
guys and show you what i have in there
okay so this isn't going to be
super detailed because actually i'm
going to lose the sun pretty soon but i
just wanted to show you guys
a little bit of my setup while i am out
here in the backcountry
so this is my sleeping bag eddie bauer
850 fill it's a 20 degree sleeping bag
super comfortable and then this
is my blow up nemo
pillow super soft this is a new pad that
i just got i'm trying it out
comfortable so far this is my second
time using it this is a little pad that
i use whenever i go camping it's super
great to just like
sit on or even just have outside your
tent um
camp stove fuel this is an insulated
thermos that i use in the morning for
coffee here
is my camera with 1635
lens and then i also
always bring this wandered camera cube
this is a little bear right now but
this is where i keep my 5d camera body
1635 lens and then also my 100 to 400
which is my favorite
favorite lens it's great for capturing
layers
especially mountain layers this little
guy right here is actually
the brain of my big backpacking backpack
and it turns into
a little backpack which i can then use
to go explore
out on the hills and the various tarns
there's
so much land to explore around here so
this is cool
it's got tons of different pockets here
i have a medical first aid kit
and then snacks i always love to bring
something fresh
so i brought um cucumber
gourmet cheese jalapeno of course um
nuts and some crackers and then i'm also
here with nate who's off in the
mountains and he brought the other half
of dinner so we're gonna make like a
little
gourmet snack platter um and then
baby wipes essential here i have some
camera gear
i have the dji osmo action and this is a
built-in tripod
um and it's also kind of like a selfie
stick that i use
and this is a phone charger which i can
use for it's usually good for like one
good charge out in the backcountry which
is
perfect it's super super slim and then i
always bring a backup
card and a backup battery these
batteries
i mean they last so long i typically
only go through one battery a trip but i
bring a second one just in case
and then this might be a little bougie
but
i always bring earplugs and also this
bare silk
eye mask just because sometimes when the
moon is out it can be really bright
and you never know like who you might be
sleeping next to if someone decides to
camp next to you it's always good to
have ear plugs
just in case and of course i have
headlamp micro spikes
um maybe i should show you how these
work
most of you are probably familiar with
them but you just strap them onto your
boots
on the bottom here and then you can
traverse over any kind of like
difficult slippery terrain especially
snow and ice
which thankfully it's mostly melted out
right now it's like
nice beautiful summer weather here is
another little contraption that i've
started using i used to always use a
bear
canister to store my food when i'm out
camping but
unless i'm doing a really long uh
through hike
i just typically stick to this and then
i'll hang it in a tree
um pretty high up but it helps with
rodents because sometimes
mice can get into your food if you just
leave food in your tent or in your
backpack
definitely want to like store it in a
safe way and i find this works pretty
well
it is armored outdoor gear but it's
called a rat sack
here's another piece of gear that i
always take with me um
this is a waterproof stuff sack by sea
to summit and i put my sleeping bag in
here and it compresses
like a really small bag and then i do
the same with my clothes so just in case
i get stuck in like a rainstorm or a
downpour
it's going to keep all of my clothes
nice and dry
over there i have some super cheap
flip-flops but
i typically wear those around camp it's
always good to have camp shoes if you
want to go like
just kind of give your feet a break and
go chill down by the water or something
so just a really quick um overview of
what i typically pack clothing wise
these pants are like super baggy but i
love them
um because they keep the mosquitoes away
like it's really hard for them to bite
through here
and then i have these leggings which i'm
typically wearing for photos they're
just a lot more photogenic
and also they keep me warmer at night i
can wear them under these pants
and i always bring down mittens because
my hands tend to get really cold
and i also have little hand warmers that
i keep inside of here
i always bring a down jacket um shorts
right now because it's summer
and then super soft like comfortable
pants to sleep in
another shirt to sleep in and then i
typically just hike out in this
the next day same with socks i'll wear a
clean pair of dry socks at night and
then i'll just hike out with them in the
morning
and then here is a long sleeve um base
layer it's super warm
smart wool and yeah i love that piece
i'll sleep in that if i get
super cold or i'll put it on as a base
layer when i'm hiking in the morning if
it's cold
and then just the beanie
and yeah that's about it for clothing oh
and i'm also wearing
a windshield rain jacket this is the big
agnes
two-person tiger wall it only weighs two
pounds
and yes leaves two people and i love the
color
it's really nice in landscapes
look at all this produce that we hauled
up into the mountains
i'm gonna cut this up and make a little
charcuterie board
oh yeah and hummus this whole tub we
have to eat it because we don't want to
hike it down
this is dinner for the evening so we've
got cucumbers jalapenos
we've got crackers nuts green pepper
avocado we have a peach and an apple for
dessert
and yeah we're gonna dig in
okay so we're gonna shoot sunrise but
it literally just started raining which
sucks
because look at these clouds oh it's
super fuzzy
so pretty hopefully the rain will stop
soon
all right we're gonna check it out again
it's raining
it's turning pink definitely gonna go
shoot some sunrise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's raining again so we're making
coffee inside the tent
everything is a little wet so this is
not the glamorous
sunrise coffee shot i was hoping for but
this
is a reality right now it's raining
again
everything is wet we're making a second
cut of coffee
and yeah life is good
packing up camp it's a little rainy out
we're gonna head back on the trail
and we're almost done we got all of our
trash
leave no chase guys always make sure
that you pack out all of your trash
trash especially toilet paper everything
leave it
just the way you found it if not better
all right
we're ready to go
all right started the hike back up and
here's an overview of the valley
see that lake we were camped right
beyond the lake behind that ridge there
and now going up
[Music]
so i forgot to mention camera clip here
this is where my camera usually hangs
where i'm shooting
have a trekking pole i have no idea what
happened to the other one but this one
comes in really handy
then i have a hat which i use with my
mosquito net
and also just to keep off the sun and
my water so i have a three liter
water bladder in my backpack keeps me
hydrated on the go
uh